This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When you're eight years old, it's not easy to say goodbye to your dad for a whole year. But that's what Andrew Marvin had to do. His dad was a commander in the Navy and was deployed to Bahrain. While his dad was away, something happened to Andrew. Every time my husband's name was brought up he would develop a headache. This is Andrew's mom, Anne-Marie Marvin. She knew her son's pain was real. She didn't want him to suffer. As she tried to figure out how to help, she remembered an episode of the TV show,
这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。当你八岁的时候，要和一个整整一年见不到面的爸爸说再见可不容易。但安德鲁·马尔文就不得不面对这一切。他的父亲是一名海军指挥官，被派往巴林执行任务。在爸爸不在的这段时间里，安德鲁发生了一些变化。每当我丈夫的名字被提起时，他就会头痛。这是安德鲁的妈妈安妮-玛丽·马尔文。她知道儿子的痛苦是真实的。她不想让他受苦。正当她绞尽脑汁想要帮忙时，她突然想起了一集电视剧：
Mash. The series is set in a fictionalized army hospital. The series is set in a fictionalized army hospital. Come on guys, let's go back to the tent, come on. The doctors had a problem on their hands. The hospital was full of wounded soldiers, but was out of painkillers. A Colonel suggested an unusual solution, treat the patients with a placebo. Here's the formula, if we believe it, they believe it. Otherwise, they're only taking sugar pills. placebo. The doctors gave out the placeboes while pretending they were real pills. Sure enough it worked. The lesson Anne-Marie took away from the scene was, make the placebo treatment look real.
《风流军医俏护士》。这部电视剧的背景设定在一个虚构的陆军医院里。这部电视剧的背景设定在一个虚构的陆军医院里。好了，伙计们，我们回帐篷去吧，走吧。医生们遇到了一大难题。医院里挤满了受伤的士兵，但止痛药却用光了。一位上校提出了一个不同寻常的解决方案——用安慰剂治疗病人。秘诀就在于：如果我们坚信不疑，他们也会深信不疑。否则，他们吃的就只是糖丸。安慰剂。医生们一边假装那些是真药，一边把安慰剂发了下去。果然，这招奏效了。安妮-玛丽从这一情节中得到的经验是：让安慰剂治疗看起来跟真的一样。
So I went to the store and I got a bottle of motron and I got a bottle of chewable vitamin C tablets and I switched the bottles. As Anne-Marie gave Andrew the vitamins, she made sure the lie didn't look like a lie. I would emphasize that he had to really have a headache. I would treat it as a would a regular drug that I wouldn't want to medicate unless absolutely necessary. On a couple rare occasions, he said it didn't work and asked for a second pill. I would make him wait 20 minutes to see if it would work first as I would a regular medication for I let him take a second one, I emphasize that I couldn't do any more than
于是我去了商店，买了一瓶美林，又买了一瓶可咀嚼的维生素C片，然后把两瓶药调换了。当安妮-玛丽把维生素片给安德鲁时，她确保这个善意的谎言看起来不露痕迹。我会强调他必须是真的头痛才能吃。我会像对待普通药物那样对待它，如果不是绝对必要，我不会想给他用药。在极少数情况下，他说没用并要求吃第二颗药。我会让他等20分钟，先看看药效是否发挥作用，就像对待普通药物一样。在他吃第二粒之前，我强调过，因为剂量的限制，我不能再给他吃更多了。
that because of the dose. Every single time we use the placebo, the headache went away, usually within about a half an hour. Anne Marie's small act of parental deception raises lots of questions. If you can make a child's headaches disappear with a vitamin, what else can you do with a placebo? What was happening in Andrew's mind and body as he took the pills? How much was the cure linked to the rituals that Anneie built into the treatment. Perhaps most difficult of all? Can you get the same results without deception?
每一次我们使用安慰剂，头痛都会消失，通常在大约半小时内。安妮-玛丽这种小小的为人父母的欺骗行为引发了许多问题。如果你能用一颗维生素让孩子的头痛消失，那你还能用安慰剂做到什么？当安德鲁吃下这些药时，他的内心和身体里发生了什么？这种治愈与安妮在治疗过程中建立的那些仪式感有多大关联？或许，最难的问题是：在没有欺骗的情况下，你能取得同样的效果吗？
These are not questions doctors generally ask. For centuries scientists have used placebo mainly to deflate the claims of conmen and to test the efficacy of drugs and medical interventions. This week on Hidden Brain, made it to theaters. Welcome to the Space Jam! Space Jam! It's your chance to your dance at the Space Jam! Alright! It was also the year of Dream Team 3. That was the nickname given to the 1996 US men's Olympic basketball team.
这些通常不是医生会问的问题。几个世纪以来，科学家使用安慰剂主要是为了揭穿骗子的谎言，以及测试药物和医疗干预措施的疗效。本周的“隐藏的大脑”，终于登陆院线了。欢迎来到《空中大灌篮》！《空中大灌篮》！这是你在《空中大灌篮》中展现舞姿的时刻！太棒了！这也是“梦三队”诞生的一年。那是1996年美国男子奥运篮球队的昵称。
They dominated the court in Atlanta. Is that the year we won the gold? This is Bruce Mosley. If you look closely at old videos of those games, you can see him sitting near the sidelines, wearing a sport jacket and tie. He was one of the physicians for the team. You might recognize some of the players Bruce is treated. Ikeem Alajuan, Shaquille O'Neal, David Robinson, Charles Barkley, Karl Malone, John Stockton, Mitch Richmond. For years Bruce worked as an orthopedic surgeon for the Houston NBA team,
他们在亚特兰大的球场上统治了比赛。那是我们赢得金牌的那一年吗？这是布鲁斯·莫斯利。如果你仔细观察那些比赛的旧录像，你可以看到他坐在场边，穿着运动夹克系着领带。他是该队的队医之一。你可能认得布鲁斯治疗过的一些球员：奥拉朱旺、沙奎尔·奥尼尔、大卫·罗宾逊、查尔斯·巴克利、卡尔·马龙、约翰·斯托克顿、米奇·里奇蒙德。多年来，布鲁斯一直担任休斯顿NBA球队休斯顿火箭队的骨科医生。
the Rockets. He performed lots of intricate surgeries. He loved seeing players glide across the court and soar in the air. He would think, that done? I have to make that happen. In a way, that's my knee. Bruce's exceptional surgical skill is what makes it so surprising that he, of all people, would lead a study that questions the primacy of surgical skill. Did I ever see myself doing this? The answer is absolutely not, and it wasn't my idea. Let's back up a second.
他做过许多复杂的手术。他喜欢看球员们在球场上滑翔并在空中翱翔。他会想，这做得到吗？我必须让它成为现实。从某种意义上说，这就是我的膝盖。布鲁斯精湛的手术技巧，让人怎么也没想到他竟然会带头开展一项质疑手术技巧至上地位的研究。我曾想过自己会做这种事吗？答案是绝对没有，而且这也不是我的主意。让我们倒退一下。
In 1989, years before he was a physician for the rockets, Bruce started working at the Baylor College of Medicine in Houston. He became interested in a knee surgery that's meant to help people with arthritis. It wasn't a common surgery where he received his medical training. And then when I came here to Houston, it seemed like surgeons were doing it almost nonstop. He founded odd that surgeons in some parts of the country were doing the procedure far more often than others. Patients reported feeling better after the surgery, but no one knew why.
1989年，在成为火箭队队医的多年前，布鲁斯开始在休斯顿的贝勒医学院工作。他开始对一种旨在帮助关节炎患者的膝关节手术产生兴趣。在他接受医学培训的地方，这不是一项常见的手术。后来当我来到休斯顿后，感觉这里的医生几乎在马不停蹄地做这个手术。他发现奇怪的是，有些地区的医生做这种手术的频率远高于其他地区。患者报告说手术后感觉好多了，但没有人知道原因。
Was it because surgeons crave away bits of tissue from the joint? Was that alleviating the pain? Or could it simply be an effect of saltwater? As part of the procedure, surgeons flush the knee with saline solution. Bruce wanted to run a trial to answer these questions. One set of patients would get the standard surgery. Another would just get their joint flushed with saline. He went to a colleague to discuss his plan. When I pitched it, she was the one that said, well, how do you know it's not all a placebo
是因为医生刮除了关节中的部分组织吗？是这个在减轻疼痛吗？还是仅仅因为盐水的作用？作为手术的一部分，医生会用生理盐水冲洗膝盖。布鲁斯想进行一项试验来回答这些问题。一组患者将接受标准手术。另一组则只用生理盐水冲洗关节。他去找一位同事商量他的计划。当我提出这个想法时，她直言不讳地说：“嗯，你怎么知道这一切不是安慰剂效应呢？”
effect? A placebo effect. The same phenomenon that helped eight-year-old Andrew Marvin and the soldiers in MASH. As a surgeon, I was like, this doesn't have anything to do with sugar pills and things like that this is surgery after all but Bruce's colleague explained to him that the placebo effect comes in many shapes and sizes if it's a small pill sometimes there's not as big a placebo effect as a bigger pill or if they say it's a new and exciting pill there's probably more of a placebo effect than a traditional pill and many times an injection's probably more of a placebo effect than a traditional pill. And many times an injection can have more of a placebo effect than a pill, and many times, some other intervention can have more of a placebo effect than an injection, and perhaps
安慰剂效应。正是这种现象帮助了八岁的安德鲁·马尔文和《风流军医俏护士》里的士兵们。作为一名外科医生，我当时想，这跟糖丸之类的一点关系都没有，这毕竟是手术啊。但布鲁斯的同事向他解释说，安慰剂效应有多种形态和大小：如果是一颗小药丸，安慰剂效应有时可能没有大药丸那么大；或者如果人们说这是一颗新奇且令人兴奋的药丸，其安慰剂效应可能比传统药丸更大；而且很多时候，注射的安慰剂效应可能比药丸更大。而且很多时候，注射可以比药丸产生更大的安慰剂效应；很多时候，其他一些干预措施又可以比注射产生更大的安慰剂效应；或许
surgery may have the biggest placebo effect of all. Sogins like brews don't think about these questions very much because the idea of comparing actual treatment to placebo treatment isn't built into the practice of surgery. If you're trying to bring a new medication to the market, you have to go through all kinds of randomized trials, including a placebo group and prove that your product is superior to the placebo treatment group. Well, surgeries don't go through that same scrutiny. Surgery's are many times adopted because it's an improvement over a previous surgery, which is an improvement on a previous surgery, which is an improvement on one before that and long story short, very few surgeries ever go through randomized trials, and almost no surgeries have a placebo control group.
手术可能拥有最大的安慰剂效应。像布鲁斯这样的外科医生不会过多思考这些问题，因为将实际治疗与安慰剂治疗进行比较的概念，并没有内置于外科手术的实践中。如果你想把一种新药推向市场，你必须经历各种随机试验，包括一个安慰剂对照组，并证明你的产品优于安慰剂治疗组。然而，外科手术并没有经历同样的审查。手术往往被采用，是因为它是对先前手术的改进，而先前手术又是对再之前手术的改进，以此类推。长话短说，极少数手术会经历随机对照试验，而且几乎没有任何手术设有安慰剂对照组。
Bruce and his team decided their study would have not two, but three groups. The first would get the real surgery. The second would have saline washed through the joint. The third would be a placebo group. Anyone who signed up was informed about the three possible kinds of treatment. We told them going in, you're going to get randomized to one of three groups and these are the three groups and we actually had them sign a piece of paper that said, I understand that I may be randomized to a control group that is a placebo group and placebo means pretend and that if I'm in this group I'll have a pretend
布鲁斯和他的团队决定，他们的研究将不设两个，而是三个组。第一组将接受真正的手术。第二组将用生理盐水冲洗关节。第三组将是安慰剂组。任何报名的人都会被告知三种可能的治疗方案。我们在他们加入时告诉他们：“你们将被随机分到三个组之一，这就是这三个组。”我们甚至让他们在一张纸上签字，上面写着：“我理解我可能会被随机分到一个对照组，即安慰剂组，安慰剂意味着假装；如果我在这一组，我将接受假手术，而不是真正的手术。”
surgery not a real surgery. And they had to write it in their own handwriting to make sure that they fully understood everything we were saying. The researchers followed certain procedures to make sure all three types of surgeries felt real to everyone involved, real to the patients and their families, and as real as possible to the physicians. Bruce would put on his crops and walk into the OR without knowing what type of surgery he was going to perform.
他们必须亲笔写下来，以确保他们完全理解我们所说的一切。研究人员遵循了某些程序，以确保所有这三种类型的手术对相关的所有人都感觉像是真的：对患者及其家属来说是真的，对医生来说也尽可能真实。布鲁斯会穿上刷手服走进手术室，却不知道自己将要做哪种手术。
He found out only when he opened an envelope. The patient would be wheeled into the room, they'd be placed onto the table, and once they're on the table we would open the randomization envelope which would disclose which of the three groups there would be placed into. All the patients were given general anesthesia. All got incisions in their knees. Patients in the first two groups received surgery or got their knees flushed with saline. And then the third group, the placebo group, they would go to sleep and make three little holes in the skin.
只有当他打开一个信封时，他才会知道。患者将被推入房间，安置在手术台上；一旦上了手术台，我们就会打开随机分配信封，从而揭晓他们将被分到三个组中的哪一组。所有患者都接受了全身麻醉。所有人的膝盖上都有切口。前两组的患者接受了手术或用生理盐水冲洗了膝盖。然后是第三组，即安慰剂组，他们会睡着，我们在皮肤上做三个小洞。
And then I wouldn't put any instruments actually inside the knee joint itself. Instead, Bruce fired up a video. I had a videotape of a real arthroscopy that had done on a patient and I would pop it in the VCR machine. We would tape all of these surgeries during this time and I would actually pretend like I was doing with the leg, what I would normally do if I was doing those different things during the real surgery. If I put something in the knee on the videotape, I would actually ask for that instrument and pretend like I was doing something. I'd
然后我实际上不会把任何器械放进膝关节本身。相反，布鲁斯播放了一段视频。我有一段对真实患者做过的关节镜检查的录像带，我会把它塞进VCR录像机里。在这个过程中，我们会把所有这些手术都录下来，我实际上会假装我在对腿做那些事，就像我在真实手术中做那些不同的事情时通常会做的那样。如果我在录像带里把什么东西放进膝盖里，我就会真的要求递那个器械，并假装我在做什么。我
move the leg around, I would splash water, we would ask and pass instruments like we were doing the real thing even though we weren't doing any real surgery. Bruce took these additional measures because he wanted to account for situations where a patient was in 100% out from the anesthesia. The other thing about that videotape was it made certain that we spent the proper amount of time under anesthesia and for instance we didn't want the placebo group where we didn't really do anything to be much shorter than the other types of surgeries so that if I went and talked to the nurses in the recovery room or the patient's family afterwards, they could look at their watch and say, oh, that was only
会移动腿，我会泼水，我们会像做真手术一样要求并传递器械，尽管我们实际上并没有做任何真正的手术。布鲁斯采取这些额外的措施，是因为他想要考虑到患者从麻醉中百分之百清醒过来的情况。关于那段录像带的另一件事是，它确保了我们在麻醉状态下花费了适当的时长；例如，我们不希望那个我们实际上什么也没做的安慰剂组的手术时间比其他类型的手术短得多，这样如果我随后去和恢复室的护士或患者家属交谈，他们就不会看一眼手表然后说：“哦，那才10分钟，所以那肯定是个安慰剂。”因此，我们在安慰剂组花在假装做手术上的时间，和我们在其他组做真实手术的时间是一样的。
10 minutes, so it must have been a placebo. So we spent the same amount of time with the placebo group pretending to do surgery as if we had done the real surgery in the other groups. In all, 180 patients, mostly men, took part in the study. Bruce followed up with them a few times over the course of two years. The results were jaw dropping. Yes, I'd say jaw dropping was probably one of the best ways to describe it. Patients in all three groups had similar functioning in their knees.
总共有180名患者（主要是男性）参与了这项研究。在两年的时间里，布鲁斯对他们进行了几次随访。结果令人震惊。是的，我可以说“令人震惊”可能是描述它的最佳方式之一。所有三组患者的膝关节功能都相似。
All three groups basically were the same. All three groups felt they were better off for having had the surgery that they'd recommend it to family and friends. They'd do it again if they had it to do all over again. And so the conclusion was that all the benefit of arthroscopic surgery to treat arthritic knees was from a placebo effect. surgery to treat arthritic knees was from a placebo effect. To Bruce, the implications were clear. We shouldn't be doing arthroscopic surgery to treat arthritic knees. And the reason is because number one, it's invasive.
这三组基本上没有什么区别。所有三组都觉得因为做了这个手术而变得更好了，他们会向家人和朋友推荐它。如果让他们从头再来一次，他们还会这么做。因此，结论是，关节镜手术治疗关节炎膝盖的所有益处都来自于安慰剂效应。治疗关节炎膝盖的所有益处都来自于安慰剂效应。对布鲁斯来说，其含义是显而易见的。我们不应该做关节镜手术来治疗关节炎膝盖。原因在于，第一，它是侵入性的。
When you do go to sleep and there is risk. And although the complication rate is very low, the chance of bad things happening is pretty low, it's not zero. And so God forbid that you ever put somebody to sleep and did a surgery on them entirely for a pretend surgery effect and they had a heart attack or a stroke or any number of other things. And you would really regret under those circumstances, you know, ever having done that.
当你入睡时，确实存在风险。尽管并发症发生率非常低，坏事发生的几率相当低，但它并非为零。因此，老天保佑，如果你曾经让某人入睡并完全为了假手术的效果而对他们进行了手术，而他们却心脏中风或发生了其他各种事情。在这种情况下，你真的会为曾经做过这样的事而后悔莫及。
Then there's the money. If you do arthroscopic knee surgery, which currently is the most commonly performed orthopedic surgery worldwide today, and you're doing it all for a placebo benefit, it's going to run into the millions, probably billions of dollars of cost. If patients are benefiting from the surgery because they're experiencing the placebo effect, Bruce says we should find other, more effective treatments and put our money there. To be clear, he doesn't want to suggest that this surgery is ineffective across the board. This is not an indictment of arthroscopic surgery.
然后是金钱问题。如果你做膝关节镜手术——这目前是全球最常进行的骨科手术——而你这一切全是为了安慰剂效益，那将产生数百万、甚至数十亿美元的成本。如果患者因为经历了安慰剂效应而从手术中受益，布鲁斯说，我们应该寻找其他更有效的治疗方法，把资金投入到那些地方。需要明确的是，他并不是想暗示这种手术在全盘上都是无效的。这不是对关节镜手术的指控。
I use arthroscopic surgery all the time to treat all kinds of things, just not arthritis, and it's not an indictment of surgery to treat arthritis. We have really effective treatments for severe arthritis, it's called a knee replacement. Brusa's study was published in the New England Journal of Medicine in 2002. Plenty of people appreciated having an evaluation of this widely used procedure. But many of Bruce's fellow orthopedic surgeons were not pleased. Oh my gosh, the vitriol that came out at the different meetings where we presented, and then if you're a surgeon, and you were routinely performing arthroscopic surgery for arthritic
我一直在使用关节镜手术来治疗各种问题，只是不包括关节炎，这也不是对治疗关节炎手术的指控。我们对严重关节炎有非常有效的治疗方法，那就是膝关节置换术。布鲁斯的研究于2002年发表在《新英格兰医学杂志》上。很多人对这项广泛使用的程序进行评估表示赞赏。但布鲁斯的许多骨科同行却很不高兴。天哪，在我们展示这项研究的不同会议上出现的尖酸刻薄之词简直难以想象；而且如果你是一名医生，如果你常规地为患有关节炎的膝盖实施关节镜手术，并且你的患者常规地告诉你他们感觉好些了，你会愿意认为这是由于你高超的手术技巧。
knees, and your patients were routinely telling you that they were better, you would like to think it's due to your surgical skill. And what my study showed, or I should say our study showed, is that it wasn't due to their surgical skill, it was due to the placebo effect, and the fact that patients were going to sleep and believing that they were having something done that would make their knees better. Orthopedic surgeons eventually came around.
而我的研究所显示的——或者我应该说我们的研究所显示的——是，这并不是由于他们高超的手术技巧，而是由于安慰剂效应，以及患者入睡并相信他们正在接受能让膝盖变得更好的治疗这一事实。骨科医生最终还是转变了观念。
Because of Bruce's study and later trials by other researchers, the American Academy of Orthopedic Surgeons does not recommend near arthroscopy in patients with arthritis. In the Yersen's Brusa study was published, other researchers have run placebo-controlled surgery studies. They've covered a range of pain-related and chronic conditions from back pain to obesity. In 2015, Bruce looked at the results. Real surgery did help lots of patients,
由于布鲁斯的研究以及其他研究人员后来的试验，美国骨科医师学会不建议对关节炎患者进行膝关节镜检查。在布鲁斯的研究发表后的几年里，其他研究人员进行了安慰剂对照的手术研究。他们涵盖了一系列与疼痛相关的慢性疾病，从背痛到肥胖。2015年，布鲁斯查看了结果。真实的手术确实帮助了许多患者，
but Bruce also found that substantial numbers of patients got better with placebo surgeries. In the case of pain, better with placebo surgeries. In the case of pain, improvements from placebo surgeries were almost the same as the improvements were from real surgeries. For Bruce, these results have led him to think about surgery in a new way. Well, it certainly makes you stop and take pause whenever we're doing a surgery purely for pain relief because from what I know now, just the act of bringing somebody to an operating room,
但布鲁斯也发现，相当数量的患者通过安慰剂手术得到了改善。在疼痛的情况下，通过安慰剂手术得到的改善与真实手术几乎没有区别。对布鲁斯来说，这些结果促使他以一种新的方式来看待手术。嗯，每当我们纯粹为了缓解疼痛而进行手术时，它肯定会让你停下来并三思而后行，因为从我现在的了解来看，仅仅是将某人带入手术室、
having them go to sleep in this fairly dramatic environment, doing some kind of procedure and having them wake up and go home and then go through a recovery. All of that fuels this very strong, emotional and psychological belief on the part of the patient that their pain is going to get better, or their shoulder is going to get better, knees are going to get better, whatever. So it certainly makes you take notice of that. But if Bruce has come to feel less confident about the power of some
让他们在这个相当戏剧化的环境中入睡、做某种手术、让他们醒来回家并经历康复的过程。所有这一切都在患者心中助长了一种非常强烈的情感和心理信念，即他们的疼痛会好转，或者他们的肩膀会好转，膝盖会好转，诸如此类。所以这肯定会引起你的注意。但如果布鲁斯对某些手术治愈能力的信心有所减弱，
surgeries to heal, he has come to feel more confident about using a power that he previously undervalued. He's realized that the treatment he offers patients isn't just about what he can do in the operating theater. It's about what comes before, what comes after. Well, I think every time I come out of surgery and go talk to a family, there are aspects of every surgery where you could probably say, I wish I'd done this better, or this could have happened a little more efficiently, and most of its subtlety nuance, it probably doesn't have anything to do with the ultimate outcome, but I always emphasize
那么他对自己以前低估的一种力量的信心却增强了。他意识到，他提供给患者的治疗不仅仅关乎他在手术室里能做什么，还关乎之前发生了什么，之后发生了什么。嗯，我想每次我做完手术出来和家属谈话时，每个手术中都有一些方面你可能会说：“我希望我能做得更好，”或者“这本来可以更有效率一点，”而且其中大部分都是细微的差别，它可能与最终的结果没有任何关系，但我总是强调
the positives when I go talk to the family that is, I share with them all the things that I'm extremely happy about, and I think by emphasizing those things rather than any kind of negatives, the patient's family gets a good feeling about it. They share those feelings with the patient. We emphasize with the patient when they come back to see me in the office the same things.
积极的一面，当我跟家属谈话时——也就是说，我与他们分享了我感到非常高兴的所有事情。我认为通过强调这些事情而不是任何消极的事情，患者家属就会对它产生一种好的感觉。他们会把这些感觉分享给患者。当患者回到办公室来看我时，我们会和患者强调同样的事情。
And so I think all of that, you're gonna harness the benefit of the placebo effect by fueling into their belief that the surgery or the procedure is going to help them be better. All of this, of course, raises tricky, ethical, and philosophical questions. Should doctors prioritize honesty with their patients about everything else? Or should they prioritize healing? Even if that occasionally involves deception. In 1778, an Austrian physician named Anton Mesmer arrived in Paris.
所以我想这一切，你将能够利用安慰剂效应的好处，去助长他们对于手术或治疗将帮助他们好转的信念。所有这一切，当然引发了棘手的伦理和哲学问题。医生是否应该在所有事情上都优先考虑对患者诚实？还是应该优先考虑治愈？即使这偶尔涉及到欺骗。1778年，一位名叫安东·梅斯默的奥地利医生抵达了巴黎。
He set up a salon to treat patients. He wanted to heal people, but his treatments involved much more flair and drama than you'd find in most doctors' offices. For one thing, he wore a distinctive outfit. Mesmer would wear a special purple robe that seemed to be designed to associate him with the signs of the zodiac and astrological power. This is Emily Ogden. She is the author of her book about Anton Mesmer and his followers.
他建立了一个沙龙来治疗病人。他想要治愈人们，但他的治疗方法比你在大多数医生办公室里看到的要更有风格和戏剧性。首先，他穿着一件独特的衣服。梅斯默会穿一件特别的紫色长袍，这似乎旨在将他与黄道十二宫的符号和占星术的力量联系起来。这是埃米莉·奥格登。她是关于安东·梅斯默及其追随者的书的作者。
She is also a professor of English at the University of Virginia. Anton Mesmer's purple robe was a hint of the theatrics that were to come. He'd gather patients in a room decorated with celestial symbols with glass harmonica music filling the air. In the middle of the room, there was a device that he called the backe. Think of a hot tub, except shorter, with a lid on top. Inside the backe, there was water and broken glass. And then rods would protrude out of it. A group of patients who suffered from a range of physical and psychological maladies sat around the backe.
她也是弗吉尼亚大学的英语教授。安东·梅斯默的紫色长袍暗示了即将上演的戏剧性场面。他将患者聚集在一个装饰着天体符号的房间里，玻璃口琴音乐充斥着空气。在房间的中央，有一个他称之为“木桶浴缸”的装置。想象一下一个热水浴缸，只是更浅一些，上面带有一个盖子。在桶里面，有水和碎玻璃。然后各种金属棒从里面伸出来。一群患有各种身体和心理疾病的患者围坐在木桶周围。
And you would have each one of them touch one of these metal rods, and he gathered around them a rope which would connect all the patients to each other. Anton Mesmer and his assistants performed a choreographed set of gestures with the patients. They would touch their diaphragms and their stomachs, they would wave iron wands over them. The iron rods were supposed to remove the obstructions in the body that cause disease. What happened to these patients after these gestures is part of what made Anton Mesmer famous and infamous. Some of them would become drowsy, others would become agitated, some would start to cough and especially cough up fluid, which was not unexpected in the context of signs of illness and humoral medicine at the time. And then some of them would undergo some really dramatic effects like convulsions, and what seemed to happen according at least to some of the observers is that
你会让每个人都触摸其中一根金属棒，他在他们周围系了一根绳子，将所有的病人相互连接起来。安东·梅斯默和他的助手们对患者进行了一套精心编排的手势。他们会触摸患者的横膈膜和胃，他们会在患者身上挥舞铁棒。这些铁棒本意是用来消除体内导致疾病的阻塞。这些患者在做完这些手势后发生了什么，正是让安东·梅斯默名声大噪（或臭名昭著）的原因之一。他们中的一些人会变得昏昏欲睡，另一些人会变得烦躁不安，有些人开始咳嗽，特别是咳出液体，这在当时疾病和体液医学的背景下并不出乎意料。然后他们中的一些人会经历一些非常戏剧性的效果，比如抽搐，而且根据至少一些观察者的说法，似乎发生的情况是：
patients would convulse, and then that convulsion would spread throughout the room. So it turned into a kind of a pandemonium of symptoms of convulsions, but then also mesmerclaimed of cures. Some patients, in fact, did get better. Anton Mesmer had a theory to explain what was going on. He thought that there was a fluid called animal magnetism that permeated the cosmos, but that was particularly active in human nerves, and he thought that through gestures and the use of special instruments, you could control the the fluid and that by controlling it you could cure
患者开始抽搐，然后这种抽搐在整个房间里蔓延开来。所以这变成了一种抽搐症状的狂乱状态，但也正如梅斯默所声称的那样，出现了治愈。事实上，一些患者确实好转了。安东·梅斯默有一个理论来解释正在发生的事情。他认为宇宙中弥漫着一种叫做“动物磁性”的流体，这种流体在人体神经中尤其活跃，他认为通过手势和特殊仪器的使用，你可以控制这种流体，并且通过控制它，你可以治愈
a wide range of diseases especially diseases that were thought of at the time as nervous diseases The physician had influential followers like the French aristocrat the Marquit de Lafayette Lafayette toured the United States to spread word about animal magnetisms, miraculous powers. If you're thinking, this is bonkers, this Mesmer Guy is a fraud, well, you and Ben Franklin have something in common. Yes, that Ben Franklin. He was appointed by the King of France to lead a commission to investigate Mesmer. The commission ran experiments to see if patients
广泛的疾病，尤其是当时被认为是神经系统疾病的疾病。这位医生拥有很有影响力的追随者，比如法国贵族拉斐特侯爵。拉斐特在全美巡回演讲，传播关于动物磁性奇迹般力量的消息。如果你在想：“这太荒谬了，这个叫梅斯默的家伙是个骗子，”好吧，那你和本·富兰克林倒是不谋而合。是的，就是那个本·富兰克林。他被法国国王任命领导一个委员会来调查梅斯默。该委员会进行了实验，以看看患者
were getting better because of animal magnetism or something else. These tests were groundbreaking. They were the first known experiments that involved what we'd now call a placebo control. Which means that they made people believe that they were magnetizing them when they were not magnetizing them, and also conversely they magnetized patients without their knowledge. The results of the experiments did exactly what Anton Mastmer's critics had hoped. They
病情好转是因为动物磁性还是其他原因。这些实验具有开创性。它们是已知最早的涉及我们现在所称的“安慰剂对照”的实验。这意味着他们让人们相信他们正在对他们进行磁化，而实际上并没有；反过来，他们也在患者不知情的情况下对其进行了磁化。实验的结果完全达到了安东·梅斯默的批评者们所希望的效果。它们
made him look like a fraud. They had one woman who was known to be magnetically susceptible and they brought her to a room, they blindfolded her and they had one of the members of the commission pretend to magnetize her but in fact he was doing nothing at all and she without any magnetization after a certain period of time went into an elaborate magnetic crisis. They did the reverse too. In one test, an investigator stood behind a panel and waved iron rods at a patient who couldn't see what was happening. She showed no effects whatsoever,
让他看起来像个骗子。他们有一名以对磁性敏感而闻名的女性，他们把她带到一个房间里，蒙上她的眼睛，让委员会的一名成员假装对她进行磁化，但实际上他什么也没做，而她在没有任何磁化的情况下，在一段时间后陷入了一场精心编排的磁性危机中。他们也做了相反的事情。在一次测试中，一名调查员站在一个屏风后面，向一个看不到发生什么的患者挥舞铁棒。她没有表现出任何效果，
although he magnetized her vigorously for some time. And so what the commissioners believe they had shown here was that the effects that Mesmer was eliciting had to do with patient belief and with the bond between the patient and the Mesmerizer and not with the animal magnetic fluid. The members of the commission believed they had humiliated Anton Mesmer. A future president of the United States made a prediction after the report came out. John Adams said it would annihilate the enthusiasm for mesmerism.
尽管他用力对她磁化了一段时间。因此，委员会成员认为他们已经证明的是，梅斯默引发的效果与患者的信念以及患者与梅斯默操作者之间的联系有关，而与动物磁性流体无关。委员会成员相信他们已经羞辱了安东·梅斯默。报告出炉后，美国未来的某位总统做出了一项预测。约翰·亚当斯说，这将消灭对梅斯默术的热情。
The debunking of Anton Mesmer, however, itself fell victim to a falsehood. Investigators did show that mesmeric techniques were no better than a placebo. Critics concluded that mesmeric techniques were no better than a placebo. Critics concluded that mesmerism was worthless. But in fact, this was not true. Some of the investigators themselves noted that while mesmer's theory of animal magnetism was nonsense, many of his techniques worked. They certainly did think that mesmer's gestures, that mesmer's pressure on the stomach, that the excitement of the public treatment salon, they thought that all of those things had their effect.
然而，对安东·梅斯默的揭穿本身也沦为了一个谎言。调查人员确实表明，梅斯默的技术并不比安慰剂好。批评者得出结论，梅斯默术毫无价值。但事实上，并非如此。一些调查人员自己指出，虽然梅斯默的动物磁性理论是无稽之谈，但他的许多技术确实管用。他们确实认为梅斯默的手势、梅斯默对胃部的压迫、公共治疗沙龙的兴奋感，所有这些事情都发挥了它们的作用。
It was just that their effect didn't happen immediately through the communication of animal magnetism, but in effect directly by the drama acting on the imagination of the patient. When people said mesmerism was worthless, they were saying that only some kinds of cures were real cures. Cures created by drama didn't count. It seems like there's been a kind of an agreement in some of these conversations that in order for a cure to be real, it has to have a physical event associated with it, not a psychological event.
只是它们的作用不是通过动物磁性的传递立即发生的，而是通过戏剧作用直接作用于患者的想象力。当人们说梅斯默术毫无价值时，他们的意思是只有某些种类的治愈才是真正的治愈。由戏剧创造的治愈不算数。似乎在其中一些对话中已经达成了一种共识，即为了让治愈成为真正的治愈，它必须伴随着一个物理事件，而不是心理事件。
What Mesma had really shown was that patients often get better not because of the doctor's skill and not because of the doctor's cure, but because of the very presence of the doctor. Ironically, most physicians have shied away from the starring role. Only some, like Benjamin Rush, a respected doctor and one of the signers of the Declaration of Independence, understood the powerful tool that Anton Mesmer had inadvertently revealed. He said at the time that he deplored Mesmer's silly
梅斯默真正表明的是，患者往往能好起来，不是因为医生的医术，也不是因为医生的药物，而是因为医生的出现本身。讽刺的是，大多数医生都避开了这个主角。只有少数人，比如本杰明·拉什——一位受人尊敬的医生、《独立宣言》的签署人之一——理解了安东·梅斯默无意中揭示的强大工具。他当时说，他痛惜梅斯默通过动物磁性治愈疾病的愚蠢
pretensions to cure by animal magnetism, but that he encouraged his medical students to avail themselves of the ability that the imagination had to cure. The dilemmas posed by this debate live on in our own time. Even today, centuries after Anton Mesmer produced convulsions in patients, most people in medicine do not believe their job is to harness their patients' imaginations. Ted Kaptchak is an exception. He believes that drama embedded in the doctor-patient relationship is deeply connected to healing. It's a focus of his research. I'm a professor of medicine at Harvard Medical School, and I'm director of the program in placebo studies at the Beth Israel Deaconess Medical Center.
自负，但他鼓励他的医学生利用想象力所具有的治愈能力。这场辩论带来的两难困境至今仍在我们的时代延续。即使在今天，在安东·梅斯默引发患者抽搐几个世纪之后，医学界的绝大多数人仍然不认为他们的工作是利用患者的想象力。特德·卡普查克是个例外。他认为医患关系中内置的戏剧性与治愈息息相关。这是他研究的重点。我是哈佛医学院的医学教授，也是贝丝以色列女执事医疗中心安慰剂研究项目的负责人。
In the 1970s, when he arrived in Cambridge, Massachusetts, he was about as far from the world of elite Western medicine as you could imagine. Ted is not a physician, he's an herbalist. He studied Chinese medicine in Macau, Taiwan, and China. He set up shop on a street in Cambridge with an unflattering reputation. I rent an apartment on Quack Row. I didn't know his Quack Row, but there were lots of all kinds of healers on the street. The whole kind of energy healers, their past life, all the new age kind of stuff was on that block. Ted's office decor was not what you might call
20世纪70年代，当他来到马萨诸塞州剑桥市时，他距离精英西方医学的世界可以说是十万八千里。特德不是医生，他是一名草药医师。他在中国澳门、台湾和大陆学习过中医。他在剑桥的一条名声不佳的街道上开了一家店。我租了一间位于“江湖骗子街”的公寓。我当时并不知道这里被称为“江湖骗子街”，但街上有各种各样的治疗师。各种能量疗法、前世今生、所有这类新时代的东西都在那个街区。特德办公室的装潢可不是你所说的那种
Boston Brahman. You know, an herbalist, so I had at least two, three hundred herbs and jars all over the waiting room and along the walls, I had really wonderful pictures of China and some of the herbs were animal parts and you know, lizards and god geckos and seahorses. Ted got positive feedback from patients all the time but there were moments that made Ted ask why exactly what patients feeling better. I see people walk into my office sit down with me for 15, 20 minutes, half hour, and sometimes I'd only write a prescription for herbs.
波士顿婆罗门风格。你知道的，作为一个草药医师，我的候诊室里以及墙边至少有两三百种草药和罐子，我有一些非常棒的中国图片，有些草药甚至是动物部位，你知道的，蜥蜴、壁虎还有海马。特德一直收到患者的积极反馈，但有时也会让特德思考，究竟是什么让患者感觉好转了。我看到人们走进我的办公室，和我坐在一起15、20分钟、半小时，有时我只开一张草药处方。
And as they walked out, I saw them walking out with less pain, more bounce in their gate, and their faces were different when they left. And I said, Ted, you just changed that person. That was not the herbs. Ted looked at traditional Chinese medical texts to help him make sense of these kinds of interactions. And I realized there was statements like the medicine should start working before the patient takes the herbs.
当他们走出去时，我看到他们的痛苦减轻了，步伐更有弹性了，离开时他们的面部表情也不一样了。我说：“特德，你刚刚改变了那个人。”那可不是草药的功用。特德查阅了传统中医文献，以帮助自己理解这类互动。我意识到其中有这样的陈述：“药物应该在患者服药之前就开始起作用。”
I started realizing that something else was going on that was more than my herbs and acupuncture. Ted asked himself what was going through the minds of his patients when they walked through his clinic door. They had hope they'd made the effort to come see him, but many had seen several doctors before him and had been disappointed. So they come with those kinds of feelings and they go into a ritual that, you know, I asked them how they are. I start talking, they expect me to ask some questions.
我开始意识到，除了我的草药和针灸之外，还有其他事情正在发生。特德问自己，当患者走进他的诊所大门时，他们的脑子里在想什么。他们抱有希望，他们付出了努力来见他，但许多人在他之前已经看过好几位医生却感到失望。所以他们带着这种感觉走进来，进入一个仪式中——你知道的，我问他们最近怎么样。我开始说话，他们期望我问一些问题。
I usually ask questions I didn't expect to make sure they knew they were getting something different. And I listened, I would lean over when I thought the patient wanted me to be a little closer. I pulled back when I saw the patient didn't want me to be closer. I would actually think and say, let me think be a little closer. I'd pull back when I saw the patient didn't want me to be closer. I would actually think, and say, let me think for a minute, if I thought the patient needed to see me be attentive. I sometimes asked people to explain things better. I got to know something about them personally
我通常会问一些他们没料到的问题，以确保他们知道自己得到了与众不同的东西。我倾听着，当我认为患者希望我靠得更近一点时，我会向前倾身。当看到患者不希望我靠得更近时，我会往后退。我实际上会思考并且说：“让我考虑一分钟，”如果我认为患者需要看到我是专心致志的。我有时会请人们把事情解释得更清楚一些。我了解了一些他们个人的情况，
that was important, so I can bring it up the next time. All those maneuvers in the context. That sounds like acting. Hey, it's a drama. Healing is a ritual in drama that everyone in the world knows, at least their cultural forms of it. That drama activates neurons
这很重要，这样我下次就可以提出来。在特定情境下的所有这些举措。这听起来像是在演戏。嘿，这就是一门戏剧。治愈是世界上每个人都知道的一种仪式和戏剧，至少有其文化形式。这种戏剧会激活神经元，
and activates a neurological process that's involved with we call now, and biomedicine at this point, the placebo effect. You got it right on the head. Ted was doing what Anton Mesmer was doing. He was using drama to unleash healing. This is where Ted's work on Quack Row and at Harvard Medical School Connect.
并激活一个涉及我们现在（在生物医学的这个阶段）称之为“安慰剂效应”的神经学过程。你完全说对了。特德在做安东·梅斯默做过的事。他正在利用戏剧来释放治愈力量。这就是特德在“江湖骗子街”和哈佛医学院的工作相通的地方。
In 1990, Harvard recruited Ted to do research on alternative medicine. The idea was his experience practicing traditional Chinese medicine would give other researchers useful perspective. At first, Ted didn't feel at home amongst the MDs and PhDs. I felt like a reptile in a mammalian environment. I was like prescientific. Gradually, Ted became more comfortable with the techniques and
1990年，哈佛招募特德来从事替代医学研究。当时的设想是，他从事传统中医的经验将为其他研究人员提供有用的视角。起初，特德在医学博士和哲学博士中感觉很不自在。我感觉自己就像是哺乳动物环境中的一只爬行动物。我当时就像是前科学时期的产物。渐渐地，特德对现代科学的技术和
norms of contemporary science. Harvard gave him research training and assigned him to some projects. They told me that your job Ted is to help us decide or discover or uncover whether any of these alternate treatments are more than a placebo effect. And I would ask my mentors, I said, so what is this placebo effect? And they said, it's the effect of an inert substance. And I said, that's an oxymoron. And I said, you know what?
规范变得更加适应。哈佛为他提供了研究培训，并指派他参与一些项目。他们告诉我：“你的工作，特德，是帮助我们决定、发现或揭示这些替代疗法中是否有任何一种不仅仅是安慰剂效应。”我会问我的导师们，我说：“那么，这个安慰剂效应到底是什么？”他们说：“这是一种惰性物质的效果。”我说：“这是一个矛盾修辞法。”我说：“你知道吗？
I'm going to make a pivot. I'm going to study the placebo effect, not alternate medicine. It's hard to overstate just how unusual that was. In the 1990s, placebos were not a subject of study. They were a tool that pharmaceutical companies and medical researchers used to figure out whether a drug or treatment was effective. If people get better, we want to know
我要做出一个战略转变。我要研究安慰剂效应，而不是替代医学。”很难过度强调这有多么不同寻常。在20世纪90年代，安慰剂并不是一个研究课题。它们是制药公司和医学研究人员用来弄清楚某种药物或治疗是否有效的工具。如果人们病情好转，我们想知道
if it's because the drug we gave them or is it spontaneous remission? Or is it because of the Dr. Patient interaction? Is it because of the ritual of taking pills? Biomedicine is really is very interested in whether a drug has a specific target that works independent of all those other factors. That's where the placebo control comes in.
这是因为我们给他们的药物，还是自发缓解？或者是由于医患互动？是因为吃药的仪式吗？生物医学真的非常关注药物是否有独立于所有这些其他因素之外起作用的具体靶点。这就是安慰剂对照发挥作用的地方。
It's a way of making medicine more like science and more scientific, and more scientific. The problem is, this can lead to the same kind of logic we heard from the people who debunked Anton Mesmer. If a drug improves patients' pain by 70%, and a placebo improves it by 70%, research us don't stop and say, wait, sugar pills are alleviating 70% of the pain. They say this drug doesn't work. In other words, cures don't count as cures
这是使医学更像科学、更加科学的一种方法。问题是，这可能会导致我们从那些揭穿安东·梅斯默的人那里听到的那种逻辑。如果一种药物将患者的疼痛减轻了70%，而安慰剂将其减轻了70%，研究人员不会停下来然后说：“等等，糖丸正在减轻70%的疼痛。”他们会说这种药物无效。换句话说，当治愈是由安慰剂引起时，
when they are caused by placebos. It totally dismisses what happens in the placebo arm of a randomized controlled trial. It says, well, this drug is no good, it's no better than placebo, where this drug is really good, it's better than placebo. Rather than dismiss the placebo effect as merely what happens in the control arm of a trial,
它们就不算数了。这完全抹杀了随机对照试验的安慰剂组中所发生的一切。它会说：“好吧，这种药物不好，它并不比安慰剂好，”或者“这种药物真的很好，它比安慰剂好。”与其将安慰剂效应仅仅视为试验对照组中发生的事情而予以驳回，
Ted decided he would study the placebo in its own right. In 2008, he published a study on treatments for irritable bowel syndrome or IBS. 262 patients were randomly assigned to one of three groups. All the patients were screened by a doctor. The first group was told to keep doing what they had been previously doing. The idea was to see if patients got better merely through the passage of time. Think of this as the time heals arm of the study.
特德决定他要就安慰剂本身进行研究。2008年，他发表了一项关于肠易激综合征（IBS）治疗的研究。262名患者被随机分配到三个组中的一组。所有患者都经过医生的筛查。第一组被告知继续做他们以前一直在做的事情。这个想法是为了看看患者是否仅仅随着时间的推移而好转。把这视为研究的“时间治愈”组。
The second group was assigned to a pretend treatment involving acupuncture needles. The last group got the pretend treatment plus a bonus. They also had a warm empathetic conversation with the acupuncturist who was trained to ask them a number of questions. Why they thought they had dealness, what made it better. We asked them how does affect their work, how does affect their lives, and we did things like touch,
第二组被指派接受涉及针灸针的假治疗。最后一组接受了假治疗外加奖励。他们还与针灸师进行了热情、富有同情心的对话，针灸师接受过训练，会向他们询问一系列问题：为什么他们认为自己生病了，是什么让病情好转。我们问他们这如何影响他们的工作，这如何影响他们的生活，我们做了一些事情，比如触碰，
attentive listening, we asked them to repeat where it's explained us what meant. Ted also gave the acupuncturist, acting advice. Ask the patient if you can be still for 20 seconds and think about them, and then ask them an important question that they would want to hear. What Ted and his colleagues did with the study was to break down the placebo effect into three components. Each arm built on the other. One, time heals. Two, time heals plus a pretend treatment.
我们请求他们复述解释的内容，来确认他们是否在专心倾听。特德还向这位针灸师提出了表演建议：询问患者是否能保持静止20秒，思考他们，然后向他们提出一个他们渴望听到的重要问题。特德和他的同事们通过这项研究，将安慰剂效应拆解为三个组成部分。每个部分都在前一个的基础上构建。第一，时间能治愈。第二，时间能治愈加上假治疗。
Three, time heals plus a pretend treatment plus warm interactions with the healthcare provider. And we got really a very straight line. We had a small placebo effect with no treatment because time heals. We had a moderate placebo effect with just a fake treatment. And then we did the full Monty. It went up to 60% improvement of adequate relief. That's an incredible amount of placebo effect. Tetted shown that the placebo effect could be valuable in its own right as a treatment.
第三，时间能治愈加上假治疗，再加上与医护人员的温情互动。我们确实得到了一条非常直观的直线。在没有治疗的情况下，由于时间能治愈，我们看到了微小的安慰剂效应。仅凭假治疗，我们看到了中等的安慰剂效应。然后我们进行了全套方案。对于获得充分缓解的改善幅度，它上升到了60%。这是一个令人难以置信的安慰剂效应。特德表明，安慰剂效应本身就可以作为一种有价值的治疗手段。
His study demonstrated that the placebo effect was made up of different factors, each of which could be deliberately employed to unleash healing. But TET also recognized that placebo's demanded something that made doctors uncomfortable. Deception. Everyone believed that deception or concealment is necessary for people to respond to Precibo, because the idea was, well, you fake people, you trick them. Precibo's kind of this trickery. And I sat with myself for a long time, read the literature, and I said, you know what? No one's tested that ever in history.
他的研究证明，安慰剂效应由不同的因素构成，每一个因素都可以被刻意运用来激发治愈。但特德也认识到，安慰剂需要一些让医生感到不舒服的东西：欺骗。每个人都认为欺骗或隐瞒是人们对安慰剂产生反应的必要条件，因为当时的观点是，你欺骗了人们，你忽悠了他们。安慰剂有点像这种骗局。我坐下来思考了很久，阅读了相关文献，然后我说，你知道吗？历史上从来没有人测试过这一点。
What's going on here? When we come back, is deception necessary for the placebo effect to work? Can honesty and the placebo effect mix? I find this just as astonishing as anybody else and I'm the patient here. There's something about sitting in a chair at a hair salon that makes people talk. It feels safe to discuss personal things.
这到底是怎么回事？当我们回来时，欺骗是安慰剂效应起作用的必要条件吗？诚实和安慰剂效应能结合吗？我对此感到和任何人一样惊讶，而且我还是这里的患者。坐在美发沙龙的椅子上，总有一些东西让人打开话匣子。讨论私事让人感觉很安全。
When clients have a cape draped around their necks and wisps of hair are falling to the floor, they gab. Oh yeah, they tell you all their problems or troubles and the good stuff, the bad stuff, yeah. This is Linda Bonanno. She's been a hairdresser in Northern Massachusetts for decades. Linda realized that people often walk out of her salon with a feeling of ease.
当顾客的脖子上披着理发长袍，碎发落到地板上时，他们就会滔滔不绝。哦，是的，他们会告诉你他们所有的烦恼或麻烦，还有美好的事、糟糕的事，是的。这是琳达·博纳诺。几十年来，她一直是马萨诸塞州北部的一名美发师。琳达意识到，人们离开她的沙龙时，常常带着一种轻松的心情。
She thinks it's because she's a good listener. How would you be able to tell when someone felt better after they had talked with you? Would you look for signs to sort of know that they were happy? You could see, you could see they have a smile on their face, their personality changes, their attitude changes, tone of their voice. Linda has also seen what such interactions look like from the opposite perspective, as someone who confides in others. That's because for many years, she's had to seek out medical care for a debilitating condition.
她认为这是因为她是一个很好的倾听者。你怎么能看出一个人在跟你谈话后感觉好些了呢？你会寻找迹象来大致了解他们是否快乐吗？你能看出来，你能看到他们脸上带着微笑，他们的个性变了，态度变了，说话的语调也变了。琳达也从相反的角度看到过这种互动，作为向他人倾诉的人。那是因为多年来，她不得不为一种使人虚弱的疾病寻求医疗护理。
I ended up with severe diarrhea and intestinal pains running through the bathroom all the time. Sometimes, the pains would come like every half an hour, I couldn't even move. It was worse than labor pains. You're better off having a baby than what I went through. It was very, very severe. The pain and diarrhea interfered with every part of Linda's life. She had to skip meals before social events. She got used to leaving gatherings early. She couldn't get work done. I used to run machinery. I worked for a medical company and I remember one time I was
我最后得了严重的腹泻和肠道疼痛，整天不停地跑洗手间。有时，疼痛每半小时就发作一次，我甚至无法动弹。这比分娩的阵痛还要糟糕。生孩子都比我经历的要好。病情非常非常严重。疼痛和腹泻干扰了琳达生活的方方面面。她在社交活动前不得不不吃饭。她习惯了早早离开聚会。她无法完成工作。我过去常常操作机械。我在一家医疗公司工作，我记得有一次我
came in over and paying. I went, oh, how am I going to run this machine? I figured I'd better go home. My boss wouldn't let me leave early. I had to wait till seven o'clock and I'm thinking, how am I going to run this machine? So thank God my buddies there, they know what I go through. They said, Linda, sit down. Don't worry about it. We'll take care of it for you until 7 o'clock comes and then you can leave. But the thing is, the episode makes me drag at least two days.
疼痛难忍地走了进来。我想，天哪，我怎么操作这台机器？我想我最好回家。我老板不让我早退。我不得不等到七点钟，我在想，我怎么操作这台机器？谢天谢地，我的朋友们都在那儿，他们知道我经历了什么。他们说，琳达，坐下。别担心。我们会帮你照顾它，直到七点钟到来，然后你就可以离开。但问题是，发作一次会让我萎靡至少两天。
I can't go to work. I can't do anything. A doctor told her she was lactose intolerant. She cut out dairy, but it didn't help. She continued to organize her life around the inevitability of pain. Linda had been suffering for a decade when an opportunity appeared on TV. It was like a commercial. The advertising came on and my eyes spurted. I went, oh, what's
我不能去上班。我什么也做不了。一位医生告诉她，她患有乳糖不耐症。她戒掉了乳制品，但这并没有帮助。她继续围绕着不可避免的痛苦来安排自己的生活。琳达已经痛苦了十年，这时电视上出现了一个机会。就像商业广告一样。广告播出了，我的眼睛睁大了。我说，哦，这是
this? A nearby hospital was conducting a study on patients within testinal problems. Linda wasn't sure she'd be a good fit, but she figured, hey, you never know. She made an appointment and took some tests. It turned out she was a good fit. She was diagnosed with irritable bowel syndrome or IBS. A physician gave Linda capsules to take twice a day. But then he told Linda something that dashed her hopes. The capsules she was about to take, they were a placebo.
什么？附近的一家医院正在对有肠道问题的患者进行一项研究。琳达不确定自己是否合适，但她想，嘿，你永远不知道。她预约并做了一些检查。事实证明她很合适。她被诊断出患有肠溶综合征，即IBS。一位内科医生给了琳达每天服用两次的胶囊。但随后医生对琳达说了一句话，击碎了她的希望。她即将服用的胶囊是安慰剂。
Oh, I was disappointed. I knew it was a sugar pill because I graduated from Hesville College as a medical assistant. So I knew a placebo was a sugar pill. And I thought he made me come all the way down here to take a sugar pill. I thought to myself why is he doing this. Why tell Linda she was getting a placebo? Wouldn't that undermine the effect of the sugar pill? Well that's what the study was supposed to test. Could a placebo help patients if they knew it was a placebo? knew it was a placebo. The study had 80 patients and was being run by Ted Capchak. It was an open-label placebo trial. Instead of deception, patients would receive what Ted is called radical honesty. The study was based on an insight. The placebo effect wasn't just about the pills. It was about an
哦，我很失望。我知道那是糖丸，因为我从赫斯维尔学院医学助理专业毕业。所以我知道安慰剂就是糖丸。我想他让我大老远跑来这里就是为了吃一颗糖丸。我心里想他为什么要这么做。为什么要告诉琳达她吃的是安慰剂？难道这不会削弱糖丸的效果吗？这正是该研究旨在测试的内容。如果患者知道是安慰剂，安慰剂还能帮助他们吗？知道是安慰剂。该研究有80名患者，由特德·卡普查克负责。这是一项开放标签的安慰剂试验。患者不会受到欺骗，而是会得到特德所说的彻底诚实。这项研究基于一个洞见。安慰剂效应不仅仅关于药丸。
edifice of drama, rituals, and the trust between patients like Linda and their doctors. Even though Linda was disappointed to get a placebo, she followed her doctor's orders. I just took them and went about my day. I said this is not gonna work if it's a sugar pill. And it wasn't till the fourth day. I realized that it wasn't sick anymore. I said this can't be." Starting on that fourth day, the pain that Linda had suffered through for a decade vanished. For three weeks, I felt fantastic.
它关乎戏剧性、仪式感的大厦，以及像琳达这样的患者与医生之间的信任。尽管琳达对拿到安慰剂感到失望，但她还是遵医嘱服用了。我只是吃了药，继续过我的一天。我说如果这是糖丸，这根本不会起作用。直到第四天。我意识到我不再生病了。我说这不可能。从第四天开始，琳达忍受了十年的痛苦消失了。有三个星期，我感觉好极了。
I had no IBS. I wasn't sick. I was taking those pills every day and I couldn't believe it." Many other patients in the study got similar relief. Volunteers who received the open label placebo reported twice the improvement in their quality of life as those who received no treatment. Now, this was a small study but Ted has looked at the effects of using open label placebos for other medical conditions.
我没有IBS。我没有生病。我每天都在吃那些药，我简直不敢相信。研究中的许多其他患者也得到了类似的缓解。接受开放标签安慰剂的志愿者报告称，他们的生活质量改善幅度是没有接受治疗的患者的两倍。现在，这是一项小型研究，但特德已经研究了将开放标签安慰剂用于其他健康状况的效果。
He's found similar, sometimes even better results, for low back pain and cancer-related fatigue. Placebos administered with radical honesty have the potential to help people. We turned the apple cart over on placebos studies. We said that everything we were saying about placebo before was actually not true, and it's probably more that it's not true. After being on the placebo for three weeks, Linda went back to her doctor. She told him how great she felt.
他发现对于下腰痛和癌症相关疲劳，疗效相似，有时甚至更好。以彻底诚实原则管理的安慰剂有可能帮助人们。我们颠覆了安慰剂研究的苹果车。我们说，以前关于安慰剂的所有说法实际上都不是真的，而且更可能是完全不真实的。在服用安慰剂三周后，琳达回到了她的医生那里。她告诉他她感觉多好。
She wanted to keep taking the pills, but the doctor said no. The study protocol only permitted patients to get placemos during the season. on how great she felt. She wanted to keep taking the pills, but the doctor said no. The study protocol only permitted patients to get placebo during the study. He said no, no, no, we can't let you keep them. I said what? I said what am I supposed to do now? He says well you'll be fine and I thought well, alright, and I'm thinking I'm not going to be fine, I know I'm not going to.
她想继续吃药，但医生说不行。研究方案只允许患者在研究期间获得安慰剂。关于她感觉有多好。她想继续吃药，但医生说不行。研究方案只允许患者在研究期间获得安慰剂。他说不，不，不，我们不能让你保留它们。我说什么？我说我现在该怎么办？他说，嗯，你会好起来的，我想，好吧，我想我不会好起来的，我知道我不会。
Linda tried to be optimistic. The first few days she didn't feel pain, so she thought the pills might have gotten rid of her IBS. But on the fourth day, the pain came back. Linda returned to her old ways of coping, taking anti-diarrhea drugs, restricting her diet, staying away from social activities. It went on for years. Finally, Linda reached out to Ted Capchak.
琳达试图保持乐观。头几天她没有感到疼痛，所以她认为这些药可能已经治好了她的IBS。但在第四天，疼痛又回来了。琳达回到了她旧的应对方式，服用止泻药，限制饮食，远离社交活动。这种情况持续了多年。最后，琳达联系了特德·卡普查克。
He agreed to take her on as a patient, and he offered to put her on a placebo once again. And then I thought, well that would be great. But then, her mind quickly jumped to concern. Okay, it worked the last time if I take it again this time, is it going to work? I thought maybe it's not going to do anything second time around. And then I would have been even more disappointed. Despite her concerns, she decided to try the placebo again. Because when you're really sick with IBS, you will do and try anything.
他同意接诊她，并提出再次让她服用安慰剂。然后我想，那太好了。但随后，她的脑海里迅速涌现出担忧。好吧，上次管用了，如果这次再吃，还会管用吗？我想也许第二次不会起作用了。那样的话，我会更加失望。尽管有这些担忧，她还是决定再次尝试安慰剂。因为当你被IBS折磨得病得很重时，你会愿意做和尝试任何事。
Anything to get rid of the pain and get back to normal. I did whatever these doctors told me to do and thank God I did because when I went back with Dr. Capchak and he put me back on the placebo, it didn't even take a week and everything was going on again. And when I think about it, I'm stunned. I don't understand it. I don't. I met a point to tell you the truth. I don't even care anymore. I just wanted to disappear and that's it. Even if Linda didn't fully understand what happened, she has some guesses about what relieved her pain. One vital factor, her deep faith,
任何能摆脱痛苦并恢复正常的方法。我照着这些医生的吩咐做了，谢天谢地我这么做了，因为当我回到卡普查克医生那里，他让我重新服用安慰剂时，甚至不到一周，一切又都好转了。每当我想起这件事，我都惊呆了。我不明白。我真的不明白。说实话，我已经无所谓了。我只希望它消失，就这样。即使琳达没有完全理解发生了什么，她对缓解疼痛的原因有一些猜测。一个至关重要的因素，她深深的信仰，
in Ted Kaptchak. He has a lot of patience, he's extremely intelligent, something about his personality, very calming. When you talk to him, you feel like you had a complete body massage. Contrast this with her impersonal interaction with a doctor who diagnosed her with lactose intolerance. He was a kind of doctor just like a patient at the deli. Of course, there are still many things we don't know. We don't fully understand why Linda got better on the placebo and why she got worse when she stopped. We don't know how generalizable her experience is to others. Would we get less impressive results if placebo became a common treatment rather than a novel one?
对特德·卡普查克的信任。他非常有耐心，极其聪明，他的个性中有一种非常平静的特质。当你和他交谈时，你会感觉像是做了一次全身按摩。这与她被诊断出乳糖不耐症时与那位医生的冷漠互动形成了鲜明对比。他那种医生，就像熟食店里的顾客一样。当然，仍有很多事情是我们不知道的。我们并不完全理解为什么琳达吃了安慰剂会好起来，以及为什么她停药后会恶化。我们不知道她的经验对其他人有多大普遍性。如果安慰剂成为一种常见疗效而非新颖疗效，我们的效果会不会不那么令人印象深刻？
What if patients obtain placebo from a pharmacy rather than from a kind doctor in a clinic? There's another problem. For some, the idea that placebo may be helpful is frustrating, even infuriating. In 2018, researchers from Northwestern University published a study showing that sugar pills can be effective in treating some patients who suffer from chronic pain. Some of the very patients who might benefit from that insight, people in chronic pain, took to Facebook to describe how demeaned they felt. One woman wrote, this is one of the worst insults to those with true chronic pain. This kind of pain is not all in their heads. They have real documented reasons
如果患者从药房而不是诊所里亲切的医生那里获得安慰剂会怎样？还有一个问题。对某些人来说，安慰剂可能有用的想法令人沮丧，甚至是激怒。2018年，西北大学的研究人员发表了一项研究，表明糖丸可以有效治疗某些患有慢性病的患者。一些本可以从这种真知灼见中受益的患者，即慢性病患者，纷纷涌向Facebook，描述他们感到的贬低。一位女性写道，这是对真正慢性病患者的最糟糕侮辱之一。这种疼痛并非全凭想象。他们有真实且有据可查的原因
to have moderate to severe pain, and offering a placebo is unethical and a grave insult. Ted understands where such criticism is coming from. People think that if a placebo works, that means a patient was faking, or that her suffering wasn't real, or that the pain was purely psychological. Ted says nothing could be further from the truth. The placebo effect is not a mind body, new age, mind cure. Those things happen not because you think, but because you do, you perform, and you enact. The placebo effect is embodied in what patients and doctors do.
来承受中度到重度的疼痛，提供安慰剂是不道德的，也是一种严重的侮辱。特德理解这种批评来自何方。人们认为，如果安慰剂有效，就意味着患者在装病，或者她的痛苦不是真实的，或者疼痛纯粹是心理上的。特德说，事实远非如此。安慰剂效应不是身心医学、新时代的心灵治愈。这些事情发生不是因为你思考，而是因为你去做，你表现，你演绎。安慰剂效应体现在患者和医生的实际行动中。
It's way below and much stronger than thinking you're going to get better and you get better. Patients are the only ones who are skeptical of the placebo effect. Some researchers are as well. My name is Azbion Rolgjartson. I'm a professor at the University of Southern Denmark. Azbion has analyzed hundreds of placebo-controlled studies. In general, he does not find a very strong placebo effect in most of the studies he reviewed. There is no indication based on the trials we looked at that there is a very large effect
这远比你认为你会好起来然后真的好起来要深得多，也强大得多。患者并不是唯一对安慰剂效应持怀疑态度的人。一些研究人员也是如此。我叫阿兹比恩·罗尔贾特森。我是南丹麦大学的教授。阿兹比恩分析了数百项安慰剂对照研究。总的来说，在他审查的大多数研究中，他并没有发现非常强的安慰剂效应。
of placebo on very many patients across very many conditions. That said, ASBION did find variations in the studies, and in some cases, he did find a large effect. The placebo effect was larger in conditions where patients reported their own outcomes, things like pain and nausea, and smaller in cases where doctors made measurements, things like hypertension. Aspion also found what Bruce mostly discovered in Houston. If a pill produces a small placebo effect, treatments that look and sound dramatic induce bigger effects. We clearly see that the more theatrical or dramatic placebo, those with needling or with
根据我们查看的试验，没有迹象表明安慰剂对非常多的病症中的非常多患者有非常大的影响。话虽如此，阿兹比恩确实在研究中发现了差异，在某些情况下，他确实发现了巨大的影响。在患者报告自身结果的病症中，安慰剂效应更大，比如疼痛和恶心，而在医生进行测量的病症中，比如高血压，效应较小。阿斯皮恩还发现了布鲁斯在休斯顿主要发现的东西。如果一颗药丸产生很小的安慰剂效应，那些看起来和听起来具有戏剧性的治疗方法会产生更大的效应。我们清楚地看到，更具戏剧性或表演性的安慰剂，那些带有针刺或带有
machines that make a sound, they tend to have larger effects. Most of the studies Aspirin looked at were testing the efficacy of various drugs. They just had a placebo arm. They were not designed to elicit the placebo effect in the way Ted Capchuck has done, they didn't focus on all the rituals around treatment. Aspion agrees that studies like those, what are sometimes called active placebo studies, could produce very different results. That's because they are designed to look beyond the effect of pills to activate things
发出声音的机器的安慰剂，往往具有更大的效果。阿斯皮恩查看的大多数研究都在测试各种药物的疗效。它们只是有一个安慰剂组。它们的设计并不是为了以特德·卡普查克那样的方式引发安慰剂效应，它们没有专注于治疗周围的所有仪式。阿斯皮恩同意，像这样的研究，有时被称为主动安慰剂研究，可能会产生非常不同的结果。这是因为它们的设计超越了药丸的效果，旨在激活
like the doctor-patient relationship. About a year into her second round of placebo treatment, Linda ended up in the hospital for back surgery. She couldn't get to Ted's office to pick up placebo pills. She was worried her IBS would office to pick up placebo pills. She was worried her IBS would return. But it didn't. Now I don't even take placebo. You know what it's like to be back to normal, to have a normal life, like everybody else, and never have to think once what condition you're in,
诸如医患关系之类的事物。在她第二轮安慰剂治疗大约一年后，琳达因背部手术住进了医院。她无法去特德的办公室拿安慰剂药丸。她担心她的IBS会办公室去拿安慰剂药丸。她担心她的IBS会复发。但它没有。现在我甚至不吃安慰剂了。你知道恢复正常是什么感觉吗，拥有正常的生活，就像其他人一样，再也不用去想你的身体状况，
or if you're going to get sick or what's going to happen, it doesn't even enter my mind. When we go to a doctor, we need two different things. The first is explicit and obvious. We want someone skilled and knowledgeable who can diagnose us correctly, who knows which pills or procedures are likely to help. But we also have implicit needs. We want someone who can attend to our suffering, not just to our illness.
或者你是否会生病，或者会发生什么，这些甚至都不会进入我的脑海。当我们去看医生时，我们需要两样不同的东西。第一样是明确且显而易见的。我们需要一个熟练且知识渊博的人，能够正确诊断我们，知道哪些药丸或程序可能会有帮助。但我们也有隐性的需求。我们需要有人关注我们的痛苦，而不仅仅是我们的疾病。
We need someone to trust in moments of fear and vulnerability. We want more than answers. We want reassurance. For overwork doctors and overburden medical systems, our explicit needs can feel more urgent than our implicit needs. Surgery and medications can seem more rigorous than the techniques to address our implicit
我们需要在恐惧和脆弱的时刻有人可以信任。我们想要的不仅仅是答案。我们需要保证。对于过度劳累的医生和超负荷的医疗系统来说，我们明确的需求可能比隐性的需求更具紧迫感。手术和药物可能比解决我们隐性需求的
needs, acting and storytelling and rituals. On top of that, these elements of performance may feel unseemly, like the behavior of snake oil salesmen. But when both kinds of needs are met, doctors and patients are more likely to get the outcome they both want. Healing This week's episode was produced by Raina Cohen. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Special thanks this week to Parth Shah and Angela C. Patrice Howard, Davis Land and Ted Meabain. Our team includes Thomas Liu and Laura Quarelle. Our unsung heroes this week are
表演、讲故事和仪式等技术显得更为严谨。最重要的是，这些表演元素可能会显得不得体，就像江湖郎中的行为。但当这两种需求都得到满足时，医生和患者更有可能得到他们都想要的结局：治愈。本周的节目由雷娜·科恩制作。由塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特剪辑。本周特别鸣谢帕思·沙阿和安吉拉·C·帕特里斯·霍华德、戴维斯·兰德以及特德·米班。我们的团队包括托马斯·刘和劳拉·夸雷尔。我们本周的无名英雄是
Wesley Cook, Ashley Davis and Yolanda Johnson. They work at the Wellness Center at NPR's headquarters in Washington DC. Members of our team have gone to them for everything from flu shots to checkups. We're lucky to have them close by and just as important to have healthcare practitioners with a great bedside manner. If you liked this episode, please share it with a friend or with your doctor. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
韦斯利·库克、阿什利·戴维斯和约兰达·约翰逊。他们在华盛顿特区NPR总部的健康中心工作。我们团队的成员曾找他们咨询过各种问题，从流感疫苗到健康检查。我们很幸运能有他们在附近，同样重要的是拥有态度极好的医疗从业人员。如果你喜欢这集节目，请把它分享给朋友或你的医生。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。你这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。